[музика]
30 січня 1933 року Адольфа Гітлера було
проголошено рейхсканцлером у повній
відповідності до тодішньої Конституції
але більшість німців на виборах 32-го
року за нього не голосували
[музика]
І хоча а не здаап отримала більшу
кількість голосів серед 12 партій у
рейхстазі це було на 2 Мільйони голосів
менше ніж на попередніх виборах
підтримка нацистів фактично йшла на спад
Коли Гітлер не очікувано став канцлером
[музика]
прийшовши до влади нацисти хочуть
зміцнити свою партію та призначають на 5
березня нові вибори
вионізовані загони партії так звані
штурмовики тризуть опонентів Але
нацистам як і раніше не вдається
отримати абсолютно більшість голосів
[музика]
щоб отримати абсолютну владу
націонал-соціалістам потрібно 2/3
голосів
тому вони створюють коаліцію з
німецького національного народної партії
та забороняють комуністичну партію що
дає їм необхідну більшість наприкінці
березня вони ухвалюють закон про
надзвичайні повноваження які по суті
позбавив парламент повноважень і
забезпечив націонал-соціалістам
диктаторську владу
[музика]
консервативні та націоналістичні еліти
Німеччини намагаються використати
Адольфа Гітлера для збереження власної
влади
але їхня недооцінка Гітлера призведе до
Другої світової війни в якій загинуть
близько 70 мільйонів людей
і Голокосту внаслідок якого було вбито 6
мільйонів євреїв а також сотні тисяч син
ті та Рома гомосексуалів Люди з
обмеженими можливостями радянських
військовополонених тощо
хоча нацисти від самого початку Ясно
заявили про свої плани створення
диктатури частина успіху Гітлера
полягала в його здатності здаватися
невинним політиком
йому вдається утихомирити консервативну
націоналістичну еліту яка потрібна йому
щоб втілити у життя свої плани із
законом про надзвичайні повноваження
прекрасний приклад лицемірства Гітлера
не святкуванні так званого дня поцдама
Де він змінює мундир на фрак і
вклоняється президенту гінденбургу
[музика]
символічний жест нова Німеччина вдає
ніби віддає шану старій Німеччині
[музика]
Гітлер також намагається завчитися
підтримкою релігійних груп поєднуючи
свою націоналістичну інфра творчість і з
біблійними метафорами як наприклад у
своїй промові у берлінському палаці
спорту
[оплески]
[музика]
день народження
Мася хочуть вірити його брехливому
обіцянкам
Адольф Гітлер при владі нацисти ледве
можуть повірити у свій успіх
але вони бояться що успіх може від них
відвернутися у ніч на 27 лютого
1933 року горить Рейхстаг
на місці пожежі затримують 24-річного
голландського комуніста маріноса вандар
насиль стверджують що це доводить спробу
комуністичного путчу
поспішно приймаються нові так звані
антитерористичні закони які дозволяють
садити у в'язницю політичних опонентів
комуністів та соціал-демократів
депортують чи вбивають у дахау в Баварії
з’являється перший концентраційний табір
вільні профспілки заборонені
небажані книги спалюються
єврей зазнають переслідувань їхнє майно
знищують або конфіскують
станом на липень 1933 року в Німеччині
залишається лише одна політична партія
нсдр
після Першої світової війни згідно з
версальським договором Німеччина мала
виплачувати репарації розмірам у
мільярди марок глобально-економічна
криза ще більше погіршила ситуацію у
1932 році безробіття в Німеччині досягло
рекорду майже
30%. У той же час демократів в Німеччині
була відносно новим явищем і не мала
великої популярності нацисти та
комуністи з'ясовують стосунки на вулицях
Берліна у повітрі зависла загроза
Громадянської війни і люди вимагали
сильного лідера насисти використали усе
це для просування своїх планівник
[музика]
[оплески]
для роботи з масами націонал-соціалісти
використовують радіотек кіно
Особливо Йозеф гебіс який досконало
опанував мистецтво пропаганди
[музика]
всю інформацію що доходить до людей
наприклад він змушує перезняти
смолоскипну ходу 30 січня тому що в день
призначених Гітлера канцлером було надто
багато перехожих
великий шанувальник інсценувань масових
заходів Він розповідає людям Саме те що
вони хочуть почути
нцях
[музика]
як рейхс-міністр пропаганди геббель
створює культ Гітлера як рятівника
німців
[музика]
улітку 1933 року гітлерівський вітання
стає обов'язковим у новій тоталітарній
нацистській Німеччині
а свастика офіційним символом
[музика]
навіть інтерв'ю з нібито журналістами за
кордону інсунуються і потім їх показують
публіці
орхідея ангела
більша частина світу спостерігає за
розвитком подій у Німеччині із сумішшю
жаху та нерозуміння
коли 2 серпня 1934 року президент
гінденбург вмирає його посаду обіймають
також Адольф Гітлер
на наступні 11 жахливих років терору
вбивств та війни у Гітлера тоталітарна
влада в Німеччині